hi this is kim from khan academy and
today i'm learning more about the first
amendment to the u.s constitution the
first amendment is one of the most
important amendments to the constitution
if not the most important
it reads
congress shall make no law respecting an
establishment of religion
or prohibiting the free exercise thereof
or abridging the freedom of speech or of
the press or the right of the people
peaceably to assemble and to petition
the government for a redress of
grievances to learn more about the first
amendment i talked to two experts erwin
chemerinsky is the jesse h chopr
distinguished professor of law and dean
of berkeley law michael mcconnell is the
director of the constitutional law
center at stanford law school and a
senior fellow at the hoover institution
professor shamarinsky there's a lot
going on in the first amendment can you
tell us a little bit more about why the
framers chose to protect these rights in
particular the historical background of
the first amendment of the constitution
shows why the framers wanted to be sure
that all of the liberties in the first
amendment were safeguarded
let's focus on freedom of speech and
freedom of the press
in england there was after the printing
press developed
licensing so that anyone who wanted to
be able to publish anything needed a
license in the government such licensing
was seen to be inconsistent with freedom
of speech freedom of the press for that
matter freedom of thought freedom of
inquiry
interesting okay so there are a lot of
essential freedoms that are packed into
this first amendment
so much that it's almost amazing that
we're gonna attempt to talk about them
all in one video
but if we dial into freedom of speech
professor mcconnell what is freedom of
speech does that encompass some things
and not others
well freedom of speech was actually less
important to the framers
than the freedom with which it was
coupled which is the freedom of the
press and the reason for this is that
speech that can reach large audiences is
much more important to the individual
but also dangerous to the state
than mere speech when you speak
only those people within hearing range
can hear you but when you are able to
use
gutenberg's fantastic new technology to
publish your sentiments and distribute
them widely maybe even over the entire
uh
country or across the atlantic and
reaching hundreds and thousands of
people now that is powerful
and
no wonder so you think about how the
american revolution was won
this required spreading the word it
required gaining converts and telling
people what their grievances were to a
very great extent this was done through
the mechanism of the printing press
when you ask the question of what's
freedom of speech there's implicit
within it the issue of
what do we mean by speech
ultimately the answer to your question
is that the first amendment in
protecting speech broadly safeguards a
right to express one's ideas but it's
not absolute the government can restrict
expression if there's a compelling
interest
interesting can you say more about that
the supreme court always has been clear
that freedom of speech is not absolute
the court has said that there are
certain categories of speech that are
unprotected by the first amendment
incitement of illegal activity is a
category of unprotected speech the court
is that this requires showing that the
speech was directed at causing imminent
illegal activity and there was a
substantial likelihood of imminent
illegal activity
another example obscenity is unprotected
by the first amendment the court
struggled for years with trying to
define what is obscenity maybe the low
point in that was when justice potter
steward said i can't define it but i
know it when i see it there are also
these categories of speech where the
government can prohibit even punish the
expression that's where most of the
limitations on the freedom of speech and
of the press come from is in order to
make sure that we don't hurt other
people's rights through the use of of
our of our own so an example of that
the government can
prohibit speech which incites
violence against someone so if you're
making a speech
and calling upon the crowd
to attack somebody's house or their
person
that can be punished and prevented
as an incitement to violence and you can
see how that follows from the logical
idea of freedom of speech being a
natural right and therefore limited by
the rights of other people so let's turn
our attention toward the
freedom of religion part of the first
amendment
so the first thing that the amendment
says
is about
establishment
so what does this establishment clause
prevent
the language of the first amendment is
important it says that congress may make
no law
respecting the establishment of religion
since 1947 the supreme court has said
that it also applies to state and local
governments and the supreme court has
said this means that the government
cannot act with the purpose of advancing
religion to the founders
this is a very clear
legal
concept namely it was the established a
church of england
in the statute books in the law the
church of england was referred to as and
i quote the church bylaw established
what did it mean to be established
first of all it meant that the doctrines
of the church
the 39 articles of faith of the church
of england
were
voted upon
by parliament so the doctrines the
liturgy the texts were all
adopted by law the established church
was the government's church
and it could be used and from time to
time was used you know as an instrument
of government or as an instrument of
politics and this is a way in which the
government is able to
have a powerful influence on the way in
which
values and opinions are inculcated
it's one of the most important
ideas of the
established church especially in the
18th century
was to teach that there's actually a
religious obligation
to
obey the law and to recognize the king
as the supreme
leader in matters of both church and
state
and
the
framers experience with this was
extremely powerful
that's because the framers were aware of
the religious persecution that had gone
on in other countries
they were aware of the evils that occur
when the government becomes aligned with
a particular religion the principal
reason why many of the colonists had
come to these shores to begin with was
to escape the oppressions of the
established church of england back home
and to come to a place where they would
be able to exercise
the freedom of religion for themselves
and the main opponents of the
established church were not
anti-christian or anti-religious people
they were the most religious people and
their view was the government should
stay out of our church that we will
decide what we believe for ourselves we
will control our own church we will
write our own liturgy we'll decide what
version of the bible we're going to use
we'll choose our own ministers thank you
very much government stay out of it
leave us free to practice our religion
without having this kind of an
establishment so for instance a county
in kentucky required that the ten
commandments be posted in all county
buildings
the supreme court said the ten
commandments are religious scripture
there's no secular purpose for having
the ten commandments posted in county
buildings the court declared it
unconstitutional the supreme court has
said the government can't act where the
primary effect is to advance or to
inhibit religion so for example there
can't be prayer in public schools even
voluntary prayer in public schools is
impermissible because the court has said
that the primary effect of having prayer
in public schools is to advance religion
the court has explained
that children will inevitably feel
pressured to participate this coercion
violates the constitution so the
first amendment then prevents
that kind of intermingling of
the government and the church this i
guess the the key idea of separation
between church and state but it also
says that
the
congress shall make no law prohibiting
the free exercise of religion so what
does that mean
free exercise of religion was the right
to practice your own religion it didn't
keep the government from setting up a
church but it did keep the government
from requiring you to
attend that church maybe even to
contribute to the church but also kept
the government from preventing you from
worshiping elsewhere so the
establishment clause by and large
prevents the government from forcing
people to participate in religion and
the free exercise clause by and large
prohibits the government from preventing
people from practicing their religion
those two things
work together
to enable everyone to
worship god in accordance with their own
conscience interesting all right so we
mentioned a little bit about freedom of
the press but there are two other
aspects of the first amendment the right
of the people peaceably to assemble and
to petition the government for a redress
of grievances
so what is included with the right
to peaceably assemble are there any
situations where that might be
restricted
the supreme court has said that under
freedom of speech there's a right to use
government property for speech purposes
this is also something that tells the
freedom of assembly and the supreme
court has said that there are certain
government properties that the
government is required to make available
for speech sidewalks in parks there's
other places where the government is
more latitude to regulating speech
school facilities evenings and weekends
there's places where the government can
close entirely to speech military bases
areas outside prisons and jails all of
these cases could have been litigated
under freedom of assembly some of the
earlier cases explicitly mentioned
freedom of assembly so subsequent cases
combine freedom of assembly into the
protection of freedom of speech
i guess that makes sense but what about
something like a
a march for example that might
say block traffic that's
perhaps a clear case when there is this
tension between freedom of speech and
assembly and say
public safety if they're blocking
say an ambulance how do you resolve that
tension
sometime in roughly the 1970s
the court began
using a quite different way of looking
at the free speech question
in which they
they said that
laws which regulate or prohibit speech
on the basis of the content of the
speech
are generally speaking unconstitutional
absent a very important governmental
purpose
but the
laws that are content neutral
and regulate speech on the basis of its
time place or manner
are permitted
so the basic idea here is that
government has regulatory authority over
speech but not over what you say but
just over
when you say it where you say it how you
say it all right so the last thing in
the first amendment is the phrase
petitioning the government for a redress
of grievances
that congress shall make no law
abridging that freedom
what does this mean how would one
petition the government for a redress of
grievances
there are of course many ways that
people can petition government for
aggressive grievances it's the ability
to go and testify before a legislative
body it's the ability to communicate
with one's legislators or
representatives about change it's
basically the ability to go to the
government and ask it to change its
policy there were relatively few cases
just about the right to petition
government for addressing grievances
again i think the reason for that is
it's been so subsumed into the
protection of freedom of speech
everything one would do by way of
petitioning government for addressing
grievances is through speech and
expression and so the larger protection
of speech and expression has meant that
the court hasn't needed to focus so much
on this particular right
is there anything that you feel people
commonly misunderstand about the first
amendment what it encompasses and what
it does not
one of the most important
misunderstandings about the first
amendment is people fail to realize that
it like all rights in the constitution
apply only to the government before i
took my current job i was a professor at
duke university in durham north carolina
duke is a private university if while i
was there i had criticized the president
of the university and he would order me
fired i could not have sued him or duke
university for violating my free speech
rights the first amendment doesn't apply
because of private university but now
i'm at the university of california a
state university if i were to give a
speech criticizing the president of the
university or the chancellor of my
campus and i was to be fired for doing
that i could sue i would sue since this
is a public university the first
amendment applies so i think the really
dangerous thing in our times
is that
many people are believe that they have
some kind of a right
not to hear opinions that they find
offensive certainly college campuses
are filled with controversies of this
sort you know this is something that
our constitution
was designed to prevent free speech can
uh inflict offense sometimes it can be
hurtful and insulting
but
we as a nation have decided
that it is better to put up with that so
that we can all be free to express
ourselves to criticize the government
to urge the religious and scientific and
artistic ideas
that we have
and that it's more important for all of
us to be able to do that
than it is to be able to
retreat to safe spaces and
and require other people to shut up
so we've learned that the rights
protected in the first amendment derive
from the historical context of
restricted speech press and religion in
europe that the framers wish to avoid in
the united states freedom of religion
includes both the freedom not to
participate in religion and the freedom
to practice whichever religion you
choose freedom of speech extends to all
forms of freedom of expression not just
words but there are limits to what
counts as free speech to learn more
about the first amendment visit the
national constitution center's
interactive constitution and khan
academy's resources on u.s government
and politics